AGNIESZKA MADURSKA: Wear OS
by Google is based on Android.
As a result, the
concepts and tools
you use for Android development
are applicable for Wear OS.
That being said, Wear OS
is a different form factor.
My name is Aga and
I will walk you
through some key differences
in wearable and mobile
development.
Before diving into
the code, it's
important to think about
the user experience
and focus on a use case
that makes sense on a watch.
If you have an
existing mobile app,
choose a core functionality
that will work well on a watch.
Once you have nailed down the
use case, design for round
screens first.
A round screen has
22% less UI space
than a rectangular
display, so this
will ensure that your layout
works on both the round
and rectangular displays.
Lastly, take your
design for a spin.
Wear OS is designed to
be used on the move.
As such, a UI design that works
well on a computer monitor
may not work in real
life on a watch.
Test your design, using at
least one Wear OS device.
Great, now you
have to locked down
the user flow and the design.
What are the development
tools available to you?
Well, in addition to the regular
Android tools such as Android
Studio, we offer APIs
and support libraries
to make your life easier.
On the platform front,
Wear OS supports the -round
and -notround identifiers
for resources.
As a result, you can have
different layouts or drawables
depending on the screen shapes.
We find that round and square
layouts tend to be the same,
so maybe two-dimension files
containing different padding
and margins are all you need.
Try it out.
In addition, we have added
a number of UI components
that are round-aware
in the Wear UI Library.
For example, the
WearablerecyclerView,
a round aware recycler view,
the BoxInsetLayout, which
keeps all the contents in the
center square of a circle,
and a SwipeDismissframeLayout,
a UI pattern
on Wear OS for dismissing views.
In addition to round
designs, Wear OS
supports always-on apps that
have longer user sessions.
By default, when the user
is not using your app,
Wear OS dismisses it and
returns to the watch face.
While this works well for
apps with a short user flow,
it works less well
when you're trying
to check items off while
shopping in the local market--
other examples include
exercise or travel apps.
That's why we created
the Always On feature.
With Always On apps, when the
user is not using your app,
the watch will go
into ambient mode,
turning off the
processor, but keeping
your app in the foreground.
This reduces battery
use while making
app-resume fast and fluid.
While your app is
in ambient mode,
you can update it once a
minute, providing useful updates
to the user.
To implement this,
your activity will
need to implement
ambiantmodesuppo
rt.ambientcallbackprovider
and tell
Wear OS how it should render the
screen while in ambient mode.
With Wear OS by Google,
you're developing
on top of a fully-featured
operating system with access
to GPU and sensors.
If you have an
existing mobile app,
consider which key user flows
makes sense for Wear OS?
Which actions will be better
on the wrist than on the phone?
So what will you make?
[MUSIC PLAYING]